all right welcome back everybody okay so
I heard that last class on Monday Scott
gave a review of MATLAB so I hope that
that was useful for everybody I kind of
skimmed over it and looked like he
covered a lot of really good stuff and
so we're gonna keep building up
proficiency in MATLAB by using it on
examples okay so today and Friday we're
gonna cover what I think is some of the
most important and interesting material
of the entire course okay so it's a
little mathematical but what we're going
to see is that using eigenvalues and
eigenvectors we can get a geometric
interpretation of the solution of any
matrix system of first order ode e's and
this is extremely powerful so this is
the basis of feedback control theory
stability theory if you want to analyze
a nonlinear system you'll often
linearize it about some fixed point and
you'll get a system of first order
equations like this and we'll want to
understand the nature of the solutions
in terms of eigenvalues and eigenvectors
okay so we're linear algebra and
ordinary differential equations meat is
probably one of the most interesting and
powerful areas of math okay both of
those fields are things that you've all
taken before but I really want to unify
them in a way that you can start you
know using these on problems that you
find interesting right now okay so I'm
going to start with some of the material
that we covered last time but a little
bit more general so now we're able to
solve any higher-order
obe as long as it's linear using the
characteristic equation right so if I
have some differential equation like
some coefficient times the nth
derivative of X plus another coefficient
a n minus one times the N minus 1
derivative of X plus dot dot plus a 3 X
triple dot plus a 2 X double dot plus a
1 X dot plus U is your X
zero okay so this is an extremely
general differential equation in the
last lecture we cooked up a system with
fourth derivatives by having spring mass
spring mass like that but if you think
about like a rubber band or some elastic
material or a polymer right there's
really a continuum of Springs and masses
and dampers and so very quickly if we
want to describe a real physical system
we might get thousands or millions or
billions of orders of differential
equations but that's fine we know how to
solve this now okay so we're going to
try some solution X of T equals e to the
lambda T we know that any nth derivative
of X is lambda to the N X pretty simple
right we just keep getting these powers
of lambda every time we take a
derivative and so this differential
equation if we plug in e to the lambda
teeth we get a and lambda to the n plus
a and minus 1 lambda to the N minus 1
plus dot dot dot plus a 3 lambda cube a
2 lambda squared a 1 lambda plus a 0
everything times X of T which is e to
the lambda T ok we're just plugging in e
to the lambda T into this equation and
we get this great characteristic
equation so I'm just going to say this
can only be equal to 0 when this
polynomial is equal to 0 okay so this is
my characteristic polynomial
I mean German speakers in the audience
so what is the German word for for
characteristic well at least an old one
is I ghen okay so eigen means latent or
characteristics so this characteristic
equation is deeply deeply connected to I
gain values of something okay and we're
gonna look at that in a minute okay so
this is a big nth order polynomial in
general I don't have a closed form
solution I have to solve this
numerically but there are in general n
lambdas that will solve this equation
okay so in general there will be n
solutions and I'm going to call them
lambda 1 lambda 2 dot dot dot all the
way up to lambda n okay there's gonna be
n numbers that solve this equation they
might be complex there might be repeated
eigenvalues that there's going to be n
of them n roots of this polynomial okay
and so the solution X at time T is going
to be written in terms of a linear
combination of Exponential's of these
eigenvalues or these lambda values so X
of T is going to be some constant times
e to the lambda 1 T plus another
constant e to the lambda 2 T plus dot
dot plus some constant e to the lambda n
T ok and this is the general solution of
this differential equation ok so if I
have my elastic medium or my fluid
equation and I have some millionth order
OD e representing that system I can find
all of the eigenvalues and I can write
my solution x as a sum of e to all of
those lambda T's ok so if I even have
one positive real part of any of these
lambdas if any of these lambdas are
positive then that term is going to blow
up to infinity
and it's gonna dominate all of my other
terms so any instability any positive
eigenvalues will always dominate and win
okay so if I want to really specify
solutions of this equation in a system
like an actual system I'm working on I
need to know what these constants are I
need to know what the mixture of these
different eigenvalues is in my problem
for my initial conditions so in general
you can use a vector of initial
conditions like X at time 0 X dot at
time 0 and you know all of these
derivatives the n minus ones derivative
at time 0 to solve for c1 c2 CN okay so
I'm going to use initial conditions in
this case I can use the value of x and
all of its derivatives at 0 and I can
solve for what these coefficients have
to be there are other initial conditions
that I could use and we'll get into that
it's you know has to do with linear
algebra and solving linear systems ok so
this is really general this is like any
high order linear differential equation
can be solved this way and it can be
solved in a computer you can find these
lambdas in a computer and you can
simulate the system and see what it'll
do for a long time ok any questions all
right this is just kind of the
generalization of what we did last
Friday but for arbitrarily high order
Odie's
okay what's really interesting though is
to start thinking about systems of
differential equations so instead of one
big equation with all of the derivatives
in one expression I might want a system
of first-order linear equations ok and
this is going to be a little bit more
general so this will solve a more
general class of problems so we have our
system
and I usually always divide through by
the largest coefficients so that this
would be have a coefficient of one right
I can just divide all of these
coefficients by a n okay so we started
to see this on Friday for I think a
third order differential equation we can
introduce new dummy variables to write
this as a system of n first order
coupled linear differential equations
okay so we're going to say X let's say X
1 equals x x 2 equals x dot X 3 equals x
double dot and X n minus 1 equals x X n
minus 1 yeah let's say X N equals the n
minus 1 derivative of X okay and so what
we have is X 1 dot X 2 dot X 3 dot dot
dot dot
okay so X 1 dots is X dot which is X 2
so X 1 dot is just X 2 X 2 dot is X
double dot that's just X 3 X 3 dot is X
4 and so on and so forth and now this
last equation is a little bit funny ok
so this last X n dot equation X n was
the n minus 1 derivative so X and dot is
the nth derivative and it equals minus
all of this stuff
right because the nth derivative plus
all of this stuff equals zero so xn dot
equals minus a naught X 1 minus a 1 X 2
minus a 3 X a 2x3
yeah a naught X 1 a 1 X 2 a 2 X 3 is X
double dot and so on minus dot dot minus
a n minus 1 times X n ok so I get this
pretty simple relationship for the first
n minus 1 variables and then the last
row equation is actually pretty
complicated this is what codes up this
entire differential equation is in this
last row ok any questions about how I
did this I went a little fast this is
pretty important any questions at all
just make sense yeah ok so this is kind
of the generalization of what we did on
Friday but for an nth order polynomial
ok and so what I can do is I can write
this as a matrix system of equations now
okay so I have some vector X 1 X 2 X 3
dot dot dot down 2 X n so I have n
variables now instead of the single X
and all of its derivatives that I had
before and DDT of this big vector is now
some matrix times that big vector X 1 X
2 X 3 all the way down to X n ok so the
first row is pretty simple X 1 dot
equals X 2 so the row that multiplies
this column vector that gives me X 2 is
0 1 0 then a bunch of zeros okay if I
multiply this row by this column I get
excellent dot equals x 2 ok that's my
first equation the next equation is X 2
dot equals X 3 then X 3 equals X 4 and
so on and so forth
ok and now the last equation is the
interesting equation so this is kind of
like a diagonal of ones and then this
last row equation is all of this stuff
here ok so we have X and dot equals
minus a 0 times X 1 minus a 1 times X 2
minus a 3 times I keep messing us up
minus a 2 times X 3 and then finally
minus a and minus 1 on the end ok so
it's a row of all of my coefficients
minus a naught minus a 1 minus a 2 dot
so we took our high order linear
differential equation and we wrote it as
a system of first-order so there's
nothing but first derivatives in this
expression which is kind of nice ok
and I can write this as a big vector y
dot equals a big matrix a times my
vector Y so this is kind of a general
system yeah on the bottom row alright so
there should be so the row right above
this is the X n minus 1 0 ok and X n
minus 1 dot is X n so it should be 0 0 0
dot dot dot dot 0 1 no so so this will
actually you know every single term here
gets a coefficient I think is that right
yeah
yes SSN is the N minus ones derivative
so X and dot does have an N minus ones
derivative term okay so there are really
coefficients on this entire bottom row
so try this for like actually by hand
for a third order differential equation
just make up coefficients and work it
out and you'll find out you know that
this really is the general expression
and it's good to do that practice
because I always get a little confused
about what the the orders are in these
okay so what we did was we took a
general single equation that was high
order in X and we wrote it as a system
of first order differential equations in
X but this matrix system of equations is
actually much more general this a could
be anything it doesn't necessarily need
this special form of just having ones
off of the diagonal and then a row of
nonzero elements on the bottom I could
have a generic
that's completely dense okay and in lots
of systems I will so in a fluid flow or
in an epidemiology model these states
might be how much Ebola is in each of
our bodies and this matrix might tell me
who I come in contact with on a daily
basis okay so there's no reason that
this has to be have this weird you know
off diagonal form I come in contact with
all of you on a daily basis and everyone
an Emmy and a daily basis and people on
my bus route and so my row has a bunch
of nonzero entries for the people that I
come in contact with maybe like all the
people in this room of the first hundred
entries and then all the people in meb
are down here somewhere
okay so I could have a generic system in
terms of a generic state and it might be
related by a big a matrix so I want to
be able to solve this type of system in
general okay so that's the general case
I'm just going to do a simple 2x2 to
make sure that this concept makes sense
okay so the example we've been working
with was X double dot plus three X dots
plus two x equals zero so this is a nice
simple damped harmonic oscillator except
here the damping is positive which means
the system is going to blow up to
infinity
okay so we're going to write this as a
matrix system of equations and make sure
that this a matrix makes sense okay so
I'm going to introduce a new dummy
variable V for the velocity of this mass
on a spring right this is just the
equation for my mass and the position X
and V is its velocity and V dot equals
minus all of this stuff so minus two X
minus three X dots which is the same as
minus two x minus 3 V because X dot is V
and so I can say DDT of my new state
vector position and velocity is equal to
some matrix times position and velocity
okay so X dot is V and V dot is minus 2
X minus 3 V so this is something we've
done before this is my a matrix this is
my Y vector my wife actor okay now it's
kind of neat is that the eigenvalues of
this a matrix are really really
important ok so what I'm going to tell
you in this lecture and in the next
lecture is that the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of this a matrix determine
everything about the solution to this
differential equation and in fact all
differential equations y dot equals a
times y every single one you can
possibly think of will be determined by
the eigenvalues and eigenvectors of a ok
so this is kind of an interesting fact
that the eigenvalues
of a our roots of the characteristic
polynomial okay so how many of you
remember how to compute the eigen value
of a 2x2 matrix
I mean if you don't quite remember how
to do it by hand okay okay so we'll do
it by hand so to compute the eigenvalues
of a matrix a you just look at the
equation determinant of a minus lambda
to the identity equals zero so we're
gonna derive this on Friday and really
you know look at why this is true but
for now just take it for granted that
solutions of this equation will be the
eigenvalues and so I have a minus lambda
times the identity that's just lambda 0
0 lambda right lambda times the identity
matrix is equal to minus lambda 1 minus
2 minus lambda minus 3 okay any minus
lambda I is this matrix and I want to
take the determinant of this matrix and
set it equal to 0 so determinants if I
have some matrix B which is b11 b12 b21
b22 then the determinant of B you just
multiply the diagonals and then subtract
the product of the off diagonals so it's
B 1 1 B 2 2 minus b12 b21 okay that's
the two-by-two formula for a determinant
so the determinant of a minus lambda I
is minus lambda times minus lambda minus
3 that's lambda squared plus 3 lambda
minus the product of the off diagonal
terms minus minus 2
as plus two equals zero so interestingly
the formula to solve for the eigen
values of a is exactly my characteristic
polynomial for my differential equation
okay this is my characteristic poly and
this is no coincidence so eigen means
characteristic the eigen value is the
solution of the characteristic
polynomial eigenvalues and eigenvectors
and differential equations were all kind
of discovered near the same time because
people wanted to solve systems of things
that changed in time okay and they found
out that eigen values told them how
these systems change in time what grows
what decays how fast and in what
direction okay so this is kind of
interesting we can take our system of
equations we can write it as a matrix
system of first order equations and the
eigenvalues of this a matrix are the
roots of the characteristic equation
okay good so there's a really close
connection between eigen values of the a
matrix and solutions of this
differential equation e to the lambda t
these would be those lambdas okay any
questions
nope
okay so in the notes there's another
example for a 3x3 sorry a third-order OD
but I'm just going to skip it right now
you can try it out at home okay
so we really want to be able to solve
general systems x equals a times X okay
or y dot equals a times y it doesn't
matter what I call this variable so we
want to be able to solve general systems
of equation X dot equals a times X so
one reason we want to be able to solve
them is because I can write any high
order linear equation as a matrix system
that's one reason I'd want to solve this
another reason is that there's a whole
bunch more types of equation types of
systems that I can model this way okay
so the disease modelling is one what
they're modeling maybe in my elastic
beam example there are additional
quantities of interest on this maybe
this is a beam that has an electrostatic
potential and I want to know not only
how the beam is moving but what the far
field you know electromagnetics looks
like so there are tons and tons of
systems that I can write in this matrix
form usually X is fairly high
dimensional doesn't have to be and so I
am going to now talk about this general
system of equations and how we solve it
okay the first case I'm going to look at
is extremely simple so if the dynamics
are uncoupled
and what I mean by uncouple dynamics is
that the dynamics for every single
element of this vector X don't depend on
any of the other elements they're only
depend on themselves okay so that is
something like if I have X 1 X 2 dot dot
dot 2 X n DDT then this only equals
lambda 1 bunch of zeros lambda to a
bunch of zeros dot dot dot dot that dot
lambda and a bunch of zeros okay does
that make sense so if my vector of
values if the time derivative only
depends on that value so X 1 dot equals
lambda 1 X 1 X 2 dot equals lambda 2 X 2
X 3 dot equals lambda 3 X 3 they don't
depend on any of the other variables so
a really simple system I like to think
of how this would come about so we
thought about bunnies reproducing
exponentially that would be X dot equals
lambda X this is like a whole zoo of
caged animals reproducing okay so x1 and
right bunnies x2 or my Lions x3 or my
zebras but nothing depends on any other
population there's no lions that can eat
bunnies
it's just exponential growth or decay of
each separate population they're caged
off okay now if I knock down all the
walls in my zoo and then I might start
getting cross terms okay I might start
getting things eating each other or
weird hybrid ligers okay so this is a
really really simple system to solve
because it's completely decoupled I just
taken a bunch of first-order equations
and written them in a complicated way
okay so I have X 1 dot equals lambda 1 X
1 X 2 dot equals lamb
2 X 2 X n dot equals lambda and X n so
what's the solution to this how do I
solve this system of differential
equations in this simple case where the
dynamics are decoupled and my a matrix
is diagonal yeah the eigenvalues are the
values on the diagonal and I can solve
each of these single equations
separately and we know how to do that ok
so I have X 1 at time T equals e to the
lambda 1 T X 1 not whatever my initial
populations of bunnies is times e to the
lambda T X 2 at time T is e to the
lambda 2 at time T times whatever my
initial population of X 2 is and so on
xn at time T equals e to the lambda n t
xn at 0 ok so they're completely
decoupled they don't depend at all on
each other kind of nice and so I can
write this you know I can I can take
this very simple solution and I can
write it in my convoluted matrix system
of equations if I want ok so I have X 1
T X 2 of T dot X n of T this is really
vector X of T is equal to a matrix with
Exponential's on the diagonal e to the
lambda 1t e to the lambda 2 T dot e to
the lambda n T zeros zeros times my
initial conditions X 1 knots X 2 knots
dot dot dot X and knots okay so this is
exactly the same as what I wrote here
this is the the solution in matrix form
okay I have exponential to the lambda
T's on the diagonal times initial
conditions
equals my solution at time T and so what
we're going to find is that we can write
this as X of T vector equals e to the
matrix 80 times a vector of initial
conditions now this makes perfect sense
when a is diagonal okay so I just gave
you the diagonal case e to a diagonal
matrix is just the diagonal of each of
the things that were on the diagonal
times a vector of initial conditions
what we haven't done is figured out what
this means this e to the a T means for a
generic a where the dynamics are coupled
okay that's where I gain values and
eigen vectors are going to come in okay
I have time for questions before I go on
are there any questions about this is
this something that most of you have
seen before okay how many of you have
not seen this before okay okay so what
this tells us is that right we want to
solve a generic system X dot equals ax
for a really nasty a just any aid that
you give me I want to be able to solve
this and what we observe from our first
case is that if a is diagonal this is
really really easy to solve right all of
the solutions decouple so what I want to
do is I want to find a change of
coordinates that makes it so that my
original system X dot equals ax looks
like a diagonal system okay I want to
diagonalize or uncouple my dynamics
through a coordinate transformation
okay right so we want this generic
system X dot equals a X and so we need a
coordinate transformation coordinate
transformation I hope starts sounding a
lot like linear algebra right matrices
are coordinate transformations so we
need a change of coordinates x equals
some matrix T times some new variable Z
okay so I had my dynamics my
differential equation written in terms
of the variable X I want to write my
differential equation in terms of a new
coordinate system Z so that my
differential equation looks diagonal so
that Z dot is equal to some diagonal
matrix times Z so what I'm going to do
here is derive the eigen value equation
I could just tell you what eigen values
and eigen vectors are and that they are
important but there is a way to motivate
it and this is probably what people did
historically was they wanted to take
they wanted to solve this nasty system X
dot equals ax they realized that if they
could find a coordinate transformation
some really really special change of
coordinates into a variable Z so that Z
dot equaled a diagonal matrix times Z
they would definitely know how to solve
it because that's easy okay and so what
we're going to do is derive a condition
on T so that this is diagonal does that
make sense so we want the special
coordinate transformation T so that our
dynamics in Z are diagonal and we're
going to derive conditions on what that
T has to look like okay so this is the
fun part
okay X dot equals T times Z dot T is
just a matrix Z is our variable it's the
thing that can change so T Z dot equals
x dot and what is X dot equal
any times that's good okay but what is X
equal T times Z okay so this is kind of
we're gonna do a lot of substitution and
this should make sense after you do it a
couple of times but it might feel a
little weird like I'm just arbitrarily
picking things to substitute in okay so
I know that I want to get an equation
entirely in terms of Z okay so I'm going
to take my X dot equation and I know
that I can either write that as TZ dot
or I can write it as a times X those are
two equivalent ways of writing X dot now
a times X is equal to a T Z so that
gives me T Z dot equals a T C please
stop me if I skip something do something
wrong if I am confusing like this is the
part where you should ask questions okay
so T times Z dot equals a times T times
Z now we have an equation entirely in Z
and I'm going to for now just assume
that I can invert T this is not always
true but I'm going to assume that I can
take the inverse of T so there's kind of
an assumption here and now I have Z dot
equals T inverse a T Z and this is the
thing that I want to equal D I want T
inverse times a times T to equal a
diagonal matrix so by any means
necessary I'm going to cook up a T so
that T inverse a T equals the diagonal
matrix that's what I want okay good so T
inverse a T equals D now the last step
and this is pretty simple I'm just going
to multiply both of these on the left by
the matrix T so when you multiply
numbers it doesn't matter if you
apply on the left or the right you know
if I have like five times this that's
the same as this times five but when you
multiply matrices it does matter if you
multiply them on the left or on the
right
so matrices don't commute eight times B
is not always equal to B times a so I'm
going to multiply both of these on the
left by T and I'm going to get a T
equals T D okay so the T that will
specifically diagonalize or the
coordinate transformation that will make
my dynamics diagonal is the T that
satisfies this equation and this is the
eigenvalue equation this is kind of the
matrix form of the eigenvalue equation
how many of you have seen the eigenvalue
equation in this kind of matrix form
okay good
so I'm just gonna write it out because I
think it's nice to see what this looks
like expanded okay so I have a big
matrix a and I have a big matrix T which
has columns t1 t2 up to TN and that's
going to equal that same big matrix t t1
t2 up to TN times what I hope is now a
diagonal matrix okay so this is going to
be lambda 1 lambda 2 up to lambda n with
zeros everywhere else okay so this is D
T T hey now every single column of T is
an eigenvector of a corresponding to
that particular eigenvalue lambda
okay so lambda 1 is an eigenvalue of a
corresponding to the eigen vector T 1
let me write this out
okay so forget all of these other
columns let's just say I have a times t1
that should be the first column on this
right-hand side which is lambda 1 t1 so
a times t1 equals lambda T 1 I also get
you know a times t2 equals lambda T 2
and so on and so forth so these columns
T and values lambda are my eigenvalues
and eigenvectors of the matrix a ok so
what does this mean geometrically what
is the kind of big picture takeaway of
this exercise any of you
if you were to reorient directions of
your stress the maximum any directions
yeah and so that that's a really nice
way of thinking about it so we have some
dynamics we know that our state X is
going to change as a function of that
state X but there are certain directions
given by the columns of T so that if I
started purely in that direction X will
stay in that direction forever okay so
my system X so these columns t define
essentially they define vectors in RN in
the n-dimensional vector space they
define these directions where the
dynamics act in a decoupled way okay so
if I started in the t1 direction my
dynamics would be decoupled and I would
just have e to the lambda 1 T times T 1
at time 0 and the same thing at t2 and
t3 and t4 so what this coordinate
transformation means is the eigenvectors
of my a matrix define a new coordinate
system ok the eigenvectors of a the
columns of the eigenvectors of a define
a new coordinate system and if I wrote
my dynamics in that coordinate system
all of the dynamics in every direction
would be completely decoupled if I
started in the first coordinate
direction the t1 direction I would
always go in the t1 direction forever
and just decay or increase in the t1
direction forever and it wouldn't depend
at all on t2 or t3 or t4 okay so what we
have here is a way of deriving a
coordinate transformation T from the
eigenvectors of our a matrix where our
dynamics become completely diagonal and
we know how to solve those diagonal
systems okay so we're gonna do some
examples and we're gonna like actually
see what this T and D look like for real
physical systems like an inverted
pendulum the spring mass damper system
and some things like that okay any
questions before I do a quick Matt
demo okay okay so the last the last bit
of this is kind of you know kind of neat
so this is really really easy to code up
in MATLAB MATLAB has built-in eigenvalue
and eigenvector solvers that are super
fast so in that lab you would just say T
comma D equals AG a that's it right so
we did this the hard way using math but
in MATLAB you can do it the easy way
right you can solve for the columns this
big matrix T of eigenvectors and d will
be a diagonal matrix with lambda 1
through lambda n using the I command ok
something interesting I want you to
think about is if a sorry if D equals T
inverse 80 then what is a equal well I
left multiply by T and I write
multiplied by T inverse so it's T DT
inverse so what is a squared
well it's TD T inverse times T DT
inverse those cancel and I get TD
squared T inverse okay 8 cubed is the
same deal I'm going to get T DT inverse
TD T inverse TD T inverse those cancel
and I have t d cubed T inverse ok so
what I want you to do before the next
lecture is to think about if I wanted to
compute a matrix e to the a T where this
is a matrix a
I can always write things as a Taylor
expansion so the way that we define this
matrix exponential I'm going to define
it as the identity matrix plus a plus 1
over 2 a squared plus 1 over 3 factorial
a cubed plus dot dot dot dot dot forever
and using this property that a squared
and a cubed and a to the N is really
really simple when you diagonalize it
you should be able to get a really
really simple expression for e to the 80
which is something like t e to the
diagonal t times matrix t inverse okay
so I want you to work this out before
next lecture this is one of the coolest
kind of properties in linear algebra is
that when you use the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of a to diagonalize the
system then it gives you a really easy
way of computing the matrix exponential
which is the solution of our
differential equation in general so
we'll go into more detail I'm going kind
of quick I want you to work this out so
that we're on the same page on on Friday
and just the last thing I'm going to
show you is how to actually use the
eigenvalue and eigenvector command in
matlab okay all of this is online and
you can also see the lecture notes good
okay so for the little system of
equations we were working with I think
we had a what was it so for the second
order differential equation the damped
spring-mass system I think we had
something like this AE equals 0 1 minus
2 minus 3 right that was the same as X
double dot plus 2 Plus 3 X dot plus 2 x
equals 0 and so now if I say TD equal I
of a super-simple i get the diagonal so
i get d
is a diagonal matrix where the diagonal
entries are the eigenvalues of a they're
also the roots of the characteristic
polynomial and the columns of t are
eigenvectors of a okay the columns of t
are eigen vectors of a so if i take a
times the first column of t yeah sorry
you can't see this very well if i take a
times the first column of t it should
equal lambda 1 times the first column of
t it should just flip the signs good it
just looked the signs okay it's the same
thing if i take a times the second
column it should flip the signs and
multiply each of these by two which it
should increase the scaling by two so a
times the second column of t all right
it's the same direction with the signs
flipped times two it's lambda two times
that column now it's kind of neat is if
I take the inverse of T times a times T
I should get my diagonal matrix back
right that was d equals inverse of T
times a times T so you really can
actually compute with this you know in
that lab it's pretty simple using the AG
command okay okay that's it for today
I'll see you all on Friday and we'll go
deeper into eigenvalues and eigenvectors
you